[Música]
manda essa música Meu cara vomita feijão
e come Fiz uma paródia
deixa o like se gostar
aplicar essa vacina em mim
[Música]
essa situação
vou ficar de recuperação
e a dormir tarde todo paredão da minha
sala eu sou pior Durmo toda aula que
complicação minha vacina eu tô com
inveja dela seu dia em casa assistindo
novela manda ela chegar com as receitas
dela não vai ter rabo laranja
[Música]
desse jeito morreu finado sequela calota
Du o Drone bom tem muita gente
lotado sempre quer para o Mário espião
coitado pobrezinho do Mário só tava
gripado
fui na farmácia Esqueci a máscara
buscar
[Música]
tudo fechado
de entregar sua subindo Comprei uma
pizza
[Música]
fico com vergonha de mim o é que
ninguém sabe para mim me olham com cara
de ruim quando eu ter consciência
o coronador não tá doente que é isso
gente você cancelado não tô parando nada
é rinite otário
só porque eu disse assim
[Música]
E aí galerinha que assiste meu canal
acho que não ia ver meu rosto por aqui
hoje achou errado otário se você gostou
dessa paródia Não esquece de clicar em
gostei hein e se você quiser você pode
comentar ali embaixo qual é a música que
você quer que eu faça uma outra paródia
hein Tá vendo vários vídeos legais bons
por aí se você ainda não é inscrito
nesse canal se inscreva tamo junto é nós
valeu